I'm excited about technology in general
how does it serve Us and how does it
serve our customers how does technology
help us develop better software faster
you know with the you know less less
issues less defects Etc how do can we
progress faster in order to bring more
value to H to our
[Music]
customers s give Greenspan welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much much
for spending this time with me I really
appreciate it how are you I'm I'm doing
well thank you for inviting me thank you
so much for joining me today sagiv
priority software let's take a step back
for a second what world are we in what
is sort of this this ecosystem that that
priority software is playing in and and
really what paino are we talking about
so priority software is um is a software
company providing products and smart
platform for managing companies in
different vertical different sizes H
solving variety of problems um we are
operating in four different lines of
business H one of them is the Erp H the
company was founded a long time ago uh
but we are now operating providing Erp
Solutions in about 30
verticals uh anything from you know
construction companies wholesale
distribution
pharmaceutical H software in large
variety so that's the Erp and we'll talk
more about that I believe the second one
is retail we are providing end to endend
the retail systems from the POS mobile
POS back end of e-commerce website
through the entire retail management
software into the
Erp and the third one is Hospitality
hotel management we are managing you
know hundreds of over actually thousands
of
hotels around the world uh check in
check out Spa events and connectivity to
all the online online booking systems
booking.com Expedia Etc and education
School management system all of them are
providing um software to manage the to
help our customers manage their business
in a more digital way more agile way
actually more effective and give better
service to their customers so that's in
a high level if if you had to take all
of these different verticals together
and and draw the line of what you know
what's common to them what sets them
apart I have some intuition from me on
on what makes that common but what what
common Trends do you see from a paino
perspective I mean why is it the
priority software is dealing with these
different verticals at the same time so
when you look at in general trends that
are in Erp but in general in in
different system so I would probably
name a few few trends that uh H emerged
in the last few
years um first of all is um
we want to give a platform that is
helping our
customers um to serve their customers
better so what what does it actually
mean it means that it gives them the
tools um to be to be more agile to move
quickly to adapt the systems to a to to
their business that is sometimes
changing very fast H so all kinds of
flexibility and adaptability Tools H
goes into
personalization and uh how do they how
do they person how does the system is
personalized to their to their needs and
and we are you know hearing
personalization in many context but when
you when you get into large systems like
Erp like retail management it has its
own its own
flavors um I would say automation
automation is definitely something that
we're putting a lot of emphasis how do
we enable our customers to shy away from
you know back end repetitive work and uh
put their effort and their energy and
their head count into a you know
Frontline Innovation rather than think
that the system can do themselves H
cloud is something that is H in the
heart of of what we do how do we H take
the entire management of the software
and do it for our customer so they can
uh H so they can focus on their own um
on their own
business and the last one that I would
mention um I would mention the user
experience how do you give them the best
user experience that uh uh that you can
offer them so they can do their work in
the most effective way MH and and how
how how common are the modules or the
building blocks of these different
solutions because you're talking about
different a different businesses
different workflows and different needs
but I'm assuming that there must be some
commonalities in terms of the
foundational building blocks from the
Integrations perspective from the
communications perspective the cloud
perspective so H how do you how do you
structure sort of the commonalities
versus differences between these
verticals so definitely there are there
are commonalities between between the
different lines of business and uh you
know as we grow bigger as we acquire
more companies we're trying to give you
know the
foundation H so the value that we
develop on one area will also be H
suitable for the other so let's say
cloud infrastructure the Cloud
infrastructure is definitely common how
do you manage you know your Cloud
infrastructure in the most optimal way
how do you harness the advantages that
you are getting from cloud and how do
you get it into value that actually is
um you know to that you can actually
provide to U you know to our customers
to the Erp users
Etc H and it goes all the way to um you
know to AI how do you take you know AI
capabilities such as forecasting and how
do you create and you know provide the
nuances that are sometimes different but
sometimes there is commonality so I will
I would separate between what I call the
infrastructure and the development tools
Etc to the application Level that is
different between uh between the
different line of business and and then
there are people that are specializing
in each industry in order to give H the
the right nuances to the right vertical
or to the right industry absolutely and
and so you talked about a little bit
about Trends and about you know being
obviously ultimately the the you talked
about user experience you talked about
Trends what we're seeing over the last
few years is is a tremendous advancement
across all um aspects of of what you're
doing right from the infrastructure
layer all the way to the user experience
layer ultimately you're you're serving
businesses which are serving other
customers and you're providing them the
tools to do that so one way of of you
know product managers if you will to
develop the right product is to really
know the End customer at the end and
understand what they
need how do you do that because you're
servicing an organization that Services
the customer so how do you ensure that
you have the right visibility into what
that customer
needs so uh it's an interesting question
I would say that you know um if I take
let's start with the with the Erp H the
Erp has you know has a a deep layer it's
not it's not thin it's fairly deep um of
what do what does an Erp user need
in order to um in order to run his
business so there are things that are
very common like the financials the
general
ledger everything that you need to do in
order to manage financials of of a
company and that's pretty similar to um
to a lot of businesses but when you get
deeper uh let's take manufacturing as an
example then you're getting deeper into
what do you need um what do you need in
order to run a Manufacturing Company
absolutely but the I think that the
tricky thing is how and that's why we
call it a platform and not just a
product because the the difference at
least in my mind or in my view between a
product and a platform that a platform
also give you Tools in order to adjust
the the product into your specific needs
so you have you have a large set of
tools in order to build the right
business processes in order to adjust it
to the way that you are manufacturing to
the way that you recognize the revenue
in financial so every in every layer of
of our product there are the tools that
we let H either our delivery team or the
customer himself or we have you know a
large set we have over 100 system
integrator companies that are taking our
product and adjust it to the exact needs
of a specific customer in a specific
industry because you know think about it
with the same Erp product we are
serving H medium siiz companies all the
way to large siiz companies in different
verticals on preman cloud all with a
single source code so basically we we're
not just offering the infrastructure and
we're not only offering the capabilities
but we're also offering the tools so
everyone can adjust it to to his
customers or to his needs incredible
okay so tell me a little bit about
yourself you know you're talking about
many verticals you're talking about the
infrastructure layer the application
layer obviously you care a lot about the
End customer and about the user
experience you're talking about you know
the goto Market strategy of working with
a system integrators that are then
taking your modules and integrating them
into in a personalized way so all around
the really really cool things H how did
you get into this what is your
background so my background actually I
started my career a long time ago 30
years ago and started as a developer my
education is a math and computer science
started the developing software a team
leader development
managers uh but in the last let's say 20
years or so I'm in this circle of H
customers Business and
Technology um different uh different
geographies lived outside of Israel H
for 16 years H moved back about eight
about eight years ago H different
Industries I was in the Telecom in the
Telecom business I was in the financial
services providing payments
infrastructure to Banks all over the
world H and in the last three years I'm
priority in Enterprise software
um and uh that's what I do so
um incredible how do you see what you're
doing with priority software fitting
into all of the different elements that
you talked about so this intersection of
of the this triangulation that you
mentioned how does priority software
enable you to fulfill your interest in
all these three
areas so if I understood your question H
correctly I would say that you know my
background in different Industries and
different
geographies gave me an understanding of
you know how do you translate customer
needs and um and the thing that you want
to provide them how do you translate it
into technology and how do you translate
them into a business and technology
basically how do you combine the two and
uh and take the company into each time
into the next level how do you expand
the value that uh that you can provide
to your customers how do you create the
the best service that you can give them
so you know the more you know experience
that you have from different Industries
different countries different roads Etc
give you a better understanding of how
do you develop strategy and then how do
you um translate it into a DAT day and
day execution because strategy is great
but without good execution you're not
getting very far absolutely okay so if
we're looking today and you know looking
down the line both on prior software but
also you know generally speaking about
this this industry and the ability for
companies like priority software to
develop these Technologies to then be
integrated and to solve a lot of these
needs of of these verticals you're
talking about from erps to the retail
Etc where where are we heading you know
software is obviously changing AI is
changing everything where where are we
heading
to so I think um you know we are heading
towards um uh towards an era where the
software you know will not replace you
know our users but the software will
become much more
friendly much more automated the you
know more more things that the software
will do for you rather than you are
working for the software
itself um you know when you talk about
the autom
how does everything that that the
software can do for you you can think
about what do you want to do and the
software will do more for you ER
personalization that I mentioned how do
you make something that the AI and
that's something we're already doing
today the system learns about your
habits to learn about what you're using
what you're not and the user experience
will change automatically in order for
you to uh to use the software in the
best way so I would say we're we are
trending towards something that will
that you know you will not feel that you
need to work hard for the software but
the software will learn what you do and
will will work will do it better for you
so absolutely and and so what are what
are you most excited about if you're
looking at where we're headed over the
next two three
years I'm excited about uh I'm excited
about technology in general
and how does the you know how does it
serve Us and how does it serve our
customers how does technology help us
develop a better software
faster H you know with the you know less
less issues less defects Etc how do can
we progress faster in order to bring
more value to a to our customers how do
we how does technology help us bring
better service to our customers how can
we you know detect issues faster before
our customers how can we you know serve
them better in different channels so the
how does technology in general help us
and how can we bring that to our to our
customers and and and how do you keep up
so obviously the last year has shown us
that it's very hard to keep up H and and
given that you're the infrastructure
layer it's perhaps you know it's
critical because every time you advance
you're effectively advancing many many
different businesses what do you do in
order to to keep up with that oh that's
a that's a tough one um you know it's
almost impossible to uh to keep up in
the pace that uh that you
want um and it's not just me it's the
entire company we are today over 500
people wow and and it's not enough it's
not enough that I will that I will be up
to date you know the entire company
needs to be H to be up to date but we
are investing a lot a lot in in
Innovation um no I listen I listen to
podcast in order to uh to be up to dat H
I'm bringing uh people from the inside
from the outside in order to enrich us
on what are the latest trends H we look
at competitors we look at the market we
try to learn a lot from from the
environment I don't think we have we are
anywhere near having a monopoly on good
ideas and I think it's perfectly fine to
learn from what others do and take you
know pick and choose the thing that uh
that you think can bring the most uh the
most to your
customers um as we acquire companies we
also acquire Talent it's not the main
reason why we do it but as we acquire we
are getting you know great people H and
the combination of people that have been
in the organization for a while and
people that are coming from the outside
and enrich us with different types of
knowledge different type of ideas Etc
this combination you know creates a good
DNA of a a cross
polination and and we are investing in
sharing knowledge so we can uh we can
move faster incredible so give I really
want to thank you for the time I don't
want I want you to go back and run the
500 plus person organization that then
Services H so many of the I guess the
businesses that I get to interact with
on the day today so thank you again for
for spending this time with me sounds
like you're right at this this
intersection of
triangulation um that that's really
interesting and so I really thank you
for for the time and I'm watching thank
you for having